Welcome back.
Well, I just-- hopefully, we
together figured out correctly
that the total time in the air
is this initial velocity in
this direction divided by 10.
That's our total time
in the air.
And now, how far is the
object going to go?
Well it's going to go, our
displacement or our distance
in this x direction is going
to be-- so, let's see, We
could call it distance in the
x direction is going to be
equal to vx, this
vx times time.
Times time in the air, right?
Times this number.
And this is the average
velocity
because it's not changing.
This is a constant.
Assuming we have no friction
or no air resistance-- air
resistance is really just
a form of friction.
The horizontal component of this
velocity is going to stay
the same the entire time.
So the total distance traveled
is going to equal this number.
Let me switch back to
that purple, so you
know what I'm doing.
v sub i square root
of 3 over 2.
That's this times the
time in the air.
Well the time in the
air is this.
Times v sub i over 10.
So the distance total traveled--
let's see.
Let's multiply these.
vi squared times the square
root of 3, all
of that over 20.
So now we know as a function
of our initial velocity in
this direction, how far is this
thing going to travel?
Well we know that we want it to
travel exactly 100 meters.
So we just set them equal
to each other.
We say 100 is equal to vi
squared times the square root
of 3 over 20.
And then we can multiply
both sides times
the inverse of this.
We could multiply both sides
by 20 and divide by the
square root of 3.
So we get v sub i squared is
equal to-- let me see.
20 times 100 is 2,000, divided
by the square root of 3.
So it's 2,000 times the
square root of 3.
And so our initial velocity we
need to shoot this thing at is
going to be the square
root of this.
So initial velocity is going to
be the square root of 2,000
divided by the square
root of 3.
So let's figure out what that
number is, just to give us a
sense of whether this
feels right.
Let me take the square root
of 3 first. 3 square root.
And let me inverse
that times 2,000.
That equals 1154.7 and then
I can square root this.
33.98.
So almost 34 meters
per second.
So my initial velocity has to be
33.98 meters per second for
me-- so my initial velocity
has to be 33.98 meters per
second to exactly hit this
target 100 meters away.
I think that is fairly cool.
And we could also do it to
figure out-- you know, we
could do it backwards to figure
out if we know exactly
what our velocity is going to
be, maybe like a slingshot--
always has the same velocity
and the only thing I can
change is the angle.
As long as we know our inverse
trigonometric functions, we
can actually figure out the
exact angle that we have to
aim the slingshot or the
catapult or whatever to hit
the target.
So I don't want you to go out
and raise your own army and
then whatever else, but if you
have to, you now know how to
command artillery.
With that, I will leave you.
And hopefully, you will not do
something overly destructive.
I'll see you soon.